next talk is by omerta Moose it will be
about learning and repeated interactions
on Networks
and like so yeah
can you hear me does the microphone work
make a test if you can hear my chewing
down
with the stragglers um
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
all right so
we're going to talk about learning on
social networks so um you know people
learn things by interacting with others
and one example you might have in mind
is uh lifestyle Choice like what to eat
do I want to put butter or margarine on
my bread or
a baby to sleep on there stomach on
their back you know the best practices
of this change over time
and we're going to think about uh a
setting where you observe
what your friends do
um and so you have to make repeated
choices every day you have to decide
what you're going to eat and You observe
what your friends do
um and and your choices are going to
influence what your friends do because
they
they observe you
um now because what I do influences my
friends and what my friends do
influences me things get very
complicated so it's going to be in
general impossible to write down an
exact equation for the
the path that these things take things
are going to depend on high order
beliefs what I think about what you
think I did something you saw me do it
now you do something I have to think oh
maybe you did this because you're
influenced by me so these are very hard
inferences so in general these things
are are not so easy to to try to
understand exactly
um
what we're going to do is is uh here's
some a preview what the model is we're
gonna have people who constantly get
information so every day I'm gonna just
be handed a little piece of information
that tells me something about this you
know whether butter or margarine is
better to eat we're gonna have a social
network so I observe some other people
I'm gonna every day observe them and act
myself this is going to be in a
completely rational framework so I'm
going to have Bayesian agents we're
going to be playing in equilibrium of a
Bayesian game trying to maximize their
utility
um and the question is how well is
information aggregated in this in this
process
okay so let me be more specific we have
a binary state of the world which is
either going to be we'll call it grb for
good or good or bad it's fixed once in
the beginning the time and let's just
say that it's half half good or bad
um we're gonna have a finite set of
agents and agents we're going to
discrete time
we're going to have a social network so
N Sub I will be all the agents that
agent I can observe
um we're going to imagine that the
network is strongly connected so
um
I guess for the computer scientists um
this is a a well-known definition but
maybe for some others
um but what it means is
that there's an indirect the path of
indirect observation from each person to
each person so maybe
um I don't um observe Grant directly but
I observe Kate who observes Grant and
this holds for any pair of of players
okay
um I'm going to have
um private signal distribution so in
each period in time each player is going
to get a private signal and these
signals are going to come from one of
two possible distributions mu G or mu B
the resolution here is not so great or
is this just my
is this a little hard to read
yeah okay
so this is a standard setting you can
imagine that maybe my signal is also a
zero or one and when the state is good
there's slightly higher probability of
getting a high signal if the state is
bad they're slightly higher probability
of getting a low signal but this is more
General you get signals from fi some
finite set and and the distribution
depends somehow on the state
um okay what's going to happen in every
period each agent gets to observe
everything that their friends did in the
past right so HTI is the history that
agent I observes which includes all the
actions of all our neighbors
um and then this agent is going to
receive one of these um private signals
that come from these two you know one of
these two distributions depending on the
state then this agent is going to choose
an action either you know put margin on
their bread or
or butter
um you're going to get a payoff
that's equal to one if the action that
you chose Max the state and zero
otherwise this is your stage payoff this
is what you get on day t
um and what you're interested in is
maximizing the
um expected discounted utility so this
discounted sum of your stage pickups
okay so basically every day we learn a
little bit about what is better we
butter our bread or margarine our bread
and then tell our friends on Facebook
what we had for breakfast and we see
what they entered
so far so good
um this defines a game and we're just
going to look at what happens in the
Nash equilibrium which means I choose a
strategy to have you know each person
chooses a strategy and given what
everybody else does what I do maximizes
my expected discounted detail
yep okay
[Music]
all but you don't observe the payoff of
your neighbors okay that's that's a good
question you don't observe your payoffs
If You observe your payoff you'd
immediately know the state right if you
so you don't observe your payoff but you
do observe a signal each period you can
think of this signal as a noisy version
of your payoff
okay so you can imagine that your payoff
is you know if you if you eat butter and
the state is butter your payoff is one
you don't observe that you observe
another random variable that's one with
probability sixty percent and zero with
probability zero percent okay okay but
notice that your actions don't influence
the information that you get so we're
not going to have your story of sort of
strategic experimentation where I take
some risky action because it gives me
more information it's just going to be
about
um I I get this information no matter
what and I just choose whatever action
or strategy more generally gives me the
highest
action
well you know it's like when you eat
butter or margin you don't observe what
it does to your heart you only get your
actual payoff you know when you die of
old age
so that's how you want to think about
this okay
um or you know every week you decide on
the weekend whether to go to the mosque
or to the church and you will only
receive your reward
foreign
margin is healthier than butter it's not
changing with time it doesn't change
with time and it's the same thing for
everybody
um but if if you want to observe your
payoffs you can think of these signals
that you get in each period as a noisy
version of your path
so that would be equivalent to
mathematical equivalent model
just based on our own signals you you
guessed the next slide yes but you're
absolutely right right so we get these
ID signals even if I didn't even look at
anybody else
I I would know the state
let me see if that's actually the next
slide
um okay so these are the signals that I
get up to time T the and the history of
what everybody else did this is what I
know at time t i don't observe payoffs
only signals and neighbors actions but I
can think of the private signals as
payoff plus noise
um and just like more it said because we
get these ID private signals again and
again and again each person is going to
eventually learn the state so this is
not like the your sequential
um learning model you know the herding
models where sometimes you don't
everybody learns the state but it might
take a long time
um the question that we're going to ask
is how fast do they learn this state so
imagine that each signal that I get is
very noisy it's only correct with
probability 51 and I get only you know I
I but but there are a lot of people so
if each person on their own might learn
very very slowly but if there's a
million of us if we put all these
signals together we'd all learn very
very quickly so the question is what's
going to happen here
um
so we're going to ask how fast they
learn but you know when when we say day
you know is everybody going to learn at
the same speed maybe some people learn
at a different speed than others this
might depend on the network
um we'll see
okay so what do I mean by the speed of
learning how fast they learn we're going
to be interested in the probability that
you get it right okay
this probability is gonna or okay here
we have the probability that you get it
wrong and this probability is going to
go to zero just because you
um you learn
um but to calculate this number exactly
you know given a good you know a network
even a very simple Network you know take
a a triangle of three agents who can
observe each other understanding in
equilibrium calculating exactly on the
10th day what is the probability that
they get it right this is completely
hopeless
um but we can say we can have some
asymptotic statement about what happens
in the long run
so
let's start with just a single agent we
don't have a network I just have me I
get a signal each period I have to make
a decision each period you can ask
what's the probability that I'm I get it
wrong on at time T and this is a
classical animation hypothesis testing
from the 50s or who knows when and what
what the result says is that the
probability that I get it wrong at time
T behaves something like e to the minus
some number R1 times T and in fact you
can calculate this number R1 this is
like a an exercise in large deviations
depending on the signal structure right
and my signal is more informative I
learn faster this R1 will be bigger if
my signal is less informative I'll learn
more slowly okay so you can so this
sorry
there's nothing patient at this point
well you know the the this is sort of
vegan right you're looking at this
probability that I match the state so
you need a prior about the state
and and the Agents when they make the
decisions they do a Bayesian calculation
they start with the prior they say the
status with probability half good really
half bad I got this information I'm
going to calculate my posterior and I'll
figure out what's the posterior
probability that the state is good or
bad
but how would you choose your action so
if I get a if I get a you know if the
signal matches the state with
probability 51 percent and I get a
signal that says okay the state is eat
butter
this this is this is
yes
in each at each time period you're just
taking action so after I see one signal
in order you know if my prior was that
butter is very very unlikely to be the
better option that even if I get a weak
signal in favor of butter it's not going
to make me take the butter action maybe
B should stand for butter
um okay so this is what happens with one
agent
um now you could ask okay what happens
if we have n agents but they have public
signals or you know they somehow all
share their signals which is not part of
our model let's imagine for a second we
have a million people now they all share
their signals but that's the same thing
as just one person
who who gets a million signals in each
period right now now we all have the
same information I don't even care I
know what you guys are all gonna do we
all have the same information we're all
going to do the same thing
so it's the same as speeding up Time by
a factor of n
right so we're just gonna learn n times
as fast so that the the probability of
making a mistake is going to shrink
exponentially again with the rate that's
n Times Higher
um so what I'm going to Define is the
speed of learning is whatever rate we
have here so I'm going to look at
I'm going to look I'm going to imagine
that the probability of making a mistake
has this form I'm going to take the log
and divide by T and take a minus and
that extracts the coefficient before the
T
okay so this is this the speed of
learning is
I Define it as R which is the limit
of the log of this probability and you
know if
if
um
if if the probability of choosing
incorrectly is of the form e to the
minus RT then this R is exactly going to
be this
okay and it turns out that looking at
these asymptotic rates these the um the
the speed of learning is tractable and
you can actually say something
even though you cannot say anything
precise about what happens in period 17
and 18.
okay so so that's that's really our main
reason for looking at these things
um
well okay you know they're they're
tractable they're but they're asymptotic
so this only tells you about what
happens you know it doesn't tell you
anything about what happens in any
particular period this is something
about the tale of the series of my
probabilities of mistakes so that's the
downside of it has no welfare
implications
um but you know it's like the I don't
know the the central limit theorem
doesn't tell you anything about what
happens when you take a sum of seven
random variables it tells you you know
at the limit so and so happens and you
sort of keep your fingers crossed that
it already happens for fiber
development
so that there would be more than
asymptotic even the asymptotic rate
would have welfare implications because
they're getting more and more precisely
the more and more people
from some motion well there's there's
the matter of sort of the order of
limits of taking time to Infinity right
so if you if as you added more people
you it would only kick in later and
later at a time like still not have
um okay now the other thing to notice is
whatever happens in our you know
remember we have n people and when if
when I'm on my own when I don't observe
anybody else this is my rate of learning
when I observe it when everybody when
observe everybody's private information
this is how quick we may learn so so
what's going to happen in whatever model
we choose in whatever Network we choose
is that the real rate has to be between
this R1 and end times I learned at least
as fast as I do on my own and I learned
it most as fast as I would if if um if
if I had all the information yeah
foreign
that's a great question now we imagine
that we all saw each other every day we
took this action would somehow see other
people's action giving the same
information as seeing their private
signals
in fact we have a previous paper that
only looks at the complete Network this
is sort of a an extension or a
collaboration on that paper and you'll
see the answer
to make them very patient and now you're
going to take a stance on a double limit
could you speak to welfare then
I also think that
is
expectations
and this isn't and we've thought a
little bit about this but let me maybe
let's maybe talk about it I think it's
still good
what about let me try one more time what
about some limit in the signal structure
as the Precision that's worse than worse
so that
it's going to change every time you make
a change it could be that the time scale
needed for this limit to actually kick
in gets larger and larger so you're
never going to know anything about what
happens at time 17.
so more I said okay I don't care about
time 17 because I'm more and more
patient but it could be that this thing
grows the time at which that you convert
to this limit grows even faster than you
have all right
um good just a quick related literature
you know this is related to bacon Victor
Wilson manages these are these
um by now classical papers on on her
behavior they have a lot of citations
this this might be an exaggeration but
they they have a lot of citations a big
it's a big industry and in fact we'll
see that in the end our conclusion is
not going to be very different from
there so I'll get back to these papers
um there's a bunch of papers including
by people in this room who do similar
exercises but not in a quite rational
model for example the Groot
um
um
um and um so these are all sorts of
variants of some you know quasi-basion
or quasi-rational or heuristic agents
um but they do have uh social networks
and signals and states and so on
um
we have some previous papers where we
did something very similar but we only
got one signal in the beginning of time
and then we asked
the same question of you know of of the
of this literature whether we learn at
all or not now we're talking about
something different everybody learns the
question is how how quickly do we learn
um and then we have another old paper
where we again do something similar but
for the complete Network
so this is this is your question where
everybody sees everybody here we also
assume that agents are myopic so they're
not they completely discount the future
and just do whatever they think is best
right now not thinking ahead here we've
also extended things to work for
strategic agents who who discount the
future and and and and play an
equilibrium of this game
um
okay so here's the result
I'm going to
fix my pair of conditional distribution
so this fixes the the signal structure
okay so for example again imagine that
the signal stick values in zero and one
and when the state is good it's slightly
higher probability of being one than
zero and vice versa and I'm going to
Define this number M which is the
highest log likelihood ratio that I get
over my entire set of possible signal
realizations okay multiplied by two so
this this sort of says when I see a
signal what's the most it can convince
me either in the direction of good or in
the direction of that
um so this is some measure of how strong
the the signals are and remember I get a
signal from this either this or this
depending on the state every period
foreign
we're going to fix the signal
distribution now you can take any
equilibrium and any social network of
any size
take any discount Factor
the speed of learning is at most m
so yeah something basically I I don't
recall two ages load Network or not
it's sort of baked into the equilibrium
assumption right so when I when I best
respond I calculate my expected utility
I need to know the network to understand
given everybody's strategies what is
going to be my utility so agents know
the network you can imagine doing this
in a state in a you know some kind of
random Network where you don't know the
network and you only see some
information about it I think it should
still work but we haven't done that
more questions
Okay so
what does this tell us it tells us you
can add more and more agents you can
make it a large complete Network you can
make it you know a two-dimensional grid
and make it larger and larger and larger
but the speed of learning is never going
to go above someone else
um Let me let me give you a numerical
example we're going to have symmetric
binary signals and so the signals are
also going to take value in in gnb and
the probability that the signal is equal
to this state is 0.9 right so I get the
somebody tells me the status G or the
state is B and they're correct with
probability is 0.9 and I get this again
and again in every period
um it turns out that a single agent's
learning speed is about 0.5 right so the
probability that I get it wrong behaves
like e to the minus 0.5 times t
um this m so the strongest possible
signal that I can get which is both of
them is is about 4.5 so what does that
mean
4.5 is an upper bound to the speed of
let of learning no matter what the
network is
um for example 10 agents with public
signals so if we took if we aggregated
perfectly the information of 10 agents
um we would have learning speed that's
bigger than 4.5 but even a million
agents that just observe the actions of
their neighbors don't learn as fast as
just these 10 agents who share their
actual data
the foundation of the serrated
information right so you're going to see
a million actions in each period but
these actions are by people who also
observe the same information as you know
everybody else's actions in the previous
periods so these are not independent
pieces of information it's more or less
the same information coming from
these issues the same energy well in
equilibrium they might you know this is
what this basically shows that an
equilibrium there's going to be a lot of
correlation here people are going to
have to choose an action that's not
going to be very informative and how to
make sense that they choose the same
action because if my signal is very weak
and I see what a million people did I'm
just going to go sorted by the majority
of what everybody is doing and so is
everybody else so this is sort of what's
going on
of course there's words also on network
so everybody has to be four or three or
whatever you want to
um and there it's a bit but you'll see
why this holds much
yes so so after the first round they
could learn really really well yeah but
the size of the network isn't changing
So asymptotically eventually this is
it's not going to be soft that's right
you know this asymptotic rate tells you
how quickly converges to zero not how
how it started moving in now if you're
talking about a completeness then it
makes sense that already in the first
period when I observe a million people I
get a very strong signal but if you're
talking about a two-dimensional grid
where everybody has four neighbors when
you grow the network you don't get
better signals in the beginning
right so so there you have a lot a lot
of people and I don't know exactly what
happens in the first periods but it's
consumable that you know you never learn
to work you just convert very slowly
um
sorry
I know these are going to be taking
actions that are just within the group
signals
okay so so we're talking about strongly
connected networks so so you prove a lot
of leaves yeah so you could ask what
let's let's talk about a particular tree
where I just have one person who
observes a million others and they
observe nobody then now I'm getting a
million independent signals at each area
that I learned very very quickly
what we do prove is that there's always
going to be at least one person who
learns this slowly who learns this slow
in heaven in your case it's the leaves
of the street
so what you do is you take the network
and you decompose it into its strongly
connected components this gives you an
undirected graph it's going to lead
somewhere these leaves now don't get any
information they're connected component
that doesn't get any information from
the outside and there we can just apply
this analysis and get very slow learning
on
more questions or thoughts or yeah
good so I think that's a good question I
don't know even on an infinite you know
it's a two-dimensional Grid or a tree or
whatever I don't know what to say about
that so this is sort of the grade 10 and
each of my kids has the grade 10 as well
it would seem like I'm learning from no
it's independent sources of information
you're saying a directory or
uh
I guess so yeah yeah then you learn very
fast
on an undirected tree if it's finite
then this theorem kicks in and we learn
slowly but at the end it's about the
asymptotics it could mean that as the
tree gets larger and larger the time in
which our learning becomes slow and
becomes later and I don't know what
would happen on an infantry that's a
good question
um
so is this is this a is this example
yeah
foreign
for the complete Network we have a
better route
that better Bound in fact it's sort of
infinitely better because it works even
for unbounded signals the bound is the
kale Divergence between the signals
which here is going to be is going to be
cyanide
um but in general could be finite even
if the signals are unbounded and I
actually think that that should also be
provable here but it's our it was
already tricky to do this and uh
somebody else
okay so let me just after thinking about
myopic and strategic Behavior so but how
much time do I have
it's 15. okay so
okay there's a game here there's some
strategy why what's the Strategic aspect
in the end if I eat butter or margarine
it only affects my health I don't care
about your health my utility is just my
own health so what why well why are we
what's there to be strategic about here
okay but there is a strategic aspect to
this the thing is that I gain
information from what from the actions
of others and my action influence other
people's actions so maybe by doing
certain things I can make you do
something that will reveal to me more of
the information that you have so what
you could imagine is that maybe I'm sort
of indifferent between butter and
margarine and but I think butter is
better and I see you doing butter
what I might do the next period is do
margarine even though I I think it's
slightly worse to see what kind of
reaction that gets from you if you stick
with butter then I know oh okay she has
a really strong butter signal here but
if you also switch over to margin then I
get I learned something about you not
having very strong information either so
you could imagine that in equilibrium
play people play these sort of games
I think that would be an interesting
paper to analyze this sort of strategic
Behavior that's not what we do what we
do is we show that in the long run you
stop playing these games and you just
act myopically and do the silly thing of
saying if my probability if my posterior
belief that butter is better is higher
than 50 percent I eat butter otherwise I
eat margarine why is that
this lit is the my log likelihood ratio
it's my belief that the state is good
given the information I know divided by
my belief that the state is bad given
the information I know
and the myopically optimal action so if
I didn't care about the future what
would I do today well if if this was
bigger than zero which is the same as my
pastier being bigger than half I would
play
um I would play G and if this was less
than zero I would play B so I'm going to
Define this amp as the myopically
optimal action for an agent who has the
same information that I have in this
game people in general are might not
take the myopic action for exactly the
reasons that I that I explained before
um
right so that you know there might be a
strategic reason not to choose MI
um
so here's two lemmas the first the
dilemma with two parts and the first one
says
in equilibrium if at some point in time
my log likelihood ratio is bigger than
this constant it just depends on Delta
on the discount Factor
then the action that I take
is the same as the myopic why is that
the thing is if I assign probability 99
percent
to butter
being uh being good and if I'm not very
patient
then the hit that I get in my utility
for playing margarine today is not worth
everything that I'll gain in the future
in expectation
from this from these mind gains
okay
the next thing is there exists some
random time T so that in equilibrium
everybody just this this happens
everybody just starts behaving
myopically from some point on why is
that well because we learn we all get
these signals
and eventually our belief is going to
convert to the truth so at some point
it's going to pass this threshold we're
going to stop behaving myopically
okay so that's the end of the not almost
the end of the Strategic part
um we just think about agents doing the
the myopically optimal thing
um yeah
I don't think so
okay maybe
I mean we can take constructed some
example in a sort of closely related
game
oh I see is playing my Opera that's a
different okay I think that they are
equilibrium where you don't play
myopically but I I also think that you
could find an example of a network where
playing myopically is not going to be an
equilibrium where you're better off
doing something strategic to
um to try to get some I I I don't have
proof of that but I think it's it's
interesting I don't know that people
have studied much these sort of things I
don't know what to call them but you
know playing playing mind games with
information like this and trying to get
you to
try to get a rise out of you to see how
good your information is I I I don't
think I think that if you're patient
it's you're not gonna hold it
um
look so here's here's the Lemma and it
tells us that all agents learn at the
same rate
so the first part says that if agent I
can observe Agent J then the rate of
agent I is going to be higher than of
age and J
which immediately implies that all
agents learn at the same rate because
the network is
is strongly connected right so if I
observe you I learn at least at your
rate
but then there's an indirect path from
you back to me and you learn you know
higher along this path and again you you
learn more quickly with it
um so the intuition is what I think Ben
called the the imitation principle
um so
um so here's the imitation principle
let's talk about my application so again
myopic agents are those that always take
it oh there he is Ben did you coin this
term the imitation principle we were
just wondering no who did
have a nice Heaven I see okay so Ben and
Evan coined it in their joint paper
um
good so for myopic agents what happens I
do the the best thing that I can
now if I observe Alex
one of the things that I can do is to do
what he did in the last period
but I'm doing something that's you know
weekly better than this I'm trying to
maximize the probability of doing the
right thing I can just imitate him
that's one thing that's open to me what
I do gives me even higher probability of
being right which tells us the
probability that I'm wrong at time T is
less than the probability that Alex who
I'm observing was wrong at time T minus
one
now if you take the logs and the limits
you'll you immediately get for myopic
agents that the rate of this person is
higher than the rate of this person
right because the difference between T
and T minus 1 goes away when you divide
by T and take the limit
but we don't have my applications we
have strategic agents and for strategic
agents even though I can observe what
Alex did I might not want to do
something that maximize my take to do
for that period I might do something
else but what we have is an imitation
principle for strategic agents
which means that the probability that I
get it wrong cannot be more than some
Factor times the probability that Alex
sorry for picking in on you someone got
it wrong
and it's sort of for the same reason
that I talked about before
there's a limit to how patient I can be
and eventually if he's he has a very
very high probability of being right and
I'm not going to want to give that up
and I will imitate him or do better
so
so what happens is
if I
observe
um Christian
once Christian's probability of getting
it right is or getting it wrong is very
very low my probability of getting it
right is also going to be very very low
up to some constant
but now when we take logs and divide by
T take the limit to Infinity the
constant is going to disappear
strategic
maybe I'm strategic two therefore it's
not so clear you want to do it
um
well I it's because I observe what you
did
I had an option of imitating I don't
have to and me I understand that you're
strategic which means that maybe you're
not doing the right thing but I always
have the option of anything
when I imitate you
I get it right with the same probability
that you better
if you get it wrong with very very low
probability
I'm not going to give up this option of
getting it wrong with that little
company so I mean somehow this is
related to the fact that the limit
people act very often because I'm going
to act myopically at the limit
you get you get this imitation principle
again up to up to
but let me maybe continue unless this is
completely entertainment we can get back
um
and and I mean you know this idea the
imitation principle maybe goes back to
cement and Sorensen and and other places
the term and then Evan and sad and
global population
thank you
um
okay so now that we have these initial
things out of the way let me tell you
why is it that our rate of learning is
bounded and no matter how many people we
have we'd never learned more than say 10
people uh in the example that we have
um so you know this is just a
restatement of the theorem
let's suppose towards a contradiction
that the learning rate is actually
strictly bigger than him I learn faster
than this than this bound
let's imagine that the state is G
so because everybody learns I know that
everybody eventually is going to take
the
the correct action
um
and the speed of where
cancer but we we had we had a claim here
because of this imitation principle
everybody learns at the same rate okay
um
now we know that the rate of learning is
R which means the probability that that
person J doesn't take the correct action
is about e to the minus RT
now when somebody observes Jay when I
say Nicole is this person Jay she gets
it wrong with probability e to the minus
RT so just me observing her if I forget
about everything and just look at her
this already gives me a very strong
signal right this one bit of what she
did in the last period gave me a very
strong signal the log likelihood ratio
just from observing her right this is
the posterior belief in the good State
condition for somebody who just gets to
observe what she did in the previous
period divided by the bad State the log
like it ratio is about RT
so I get this very very strong signal
from looking at her
now
I also have my private signals and I got
two of them because we're at time T each
one of them the strongest it could be is
m
so all of these private signals put
together
the log likelihood ratio is between
minus Mt and Mt
so the strongest possible signal that
you know if I got a positive signal from
her the log likelihood ratio is RT
for me to do the other thing my private
signal needs to be less than minus RT so
they put together put together
um my belief is less than a half
that makes sense
this is impossible because each signal
that I get has strength at most M so
when I put T of these together the log
likelihood ratio just sums up these are
conditionally independent signal the sum
of these signals cannot be that strong
so you know maybe if you're not used to
thinking about log likelihood ratios but
basically here's what happens if the
probability that we all get it wrong
decreases very very fast
then the social information that we get
becomes much stronger than our own
private signals
right it doesn't matter even if all my
private signals told me bad bad bad bad
bad bad the fact that everybody's doing
good trumps that so then I don't even
look at my private signals anymore I
just do what everybody else does this is
exactly the same mechanism from
Victorious Life Aaron Wells where social
learning stopped because people stop
looking at their own private signals
okay
quite much
for this because it could be like e to
the power minus Mt plus n right
minus empty we made a degree the degree
right the degree right so but T really
has to be large like yes it could be as
and grows T might have to also grow yeah
exactly so that's one of the
disadvantages of this asymptote
it would be very nice so you know this
is why I don't know how to say anything
but the infinitely two-dimensional grid
really nice to get something you know
some kind of uniform convergence or
understand that it doesn't happen that
would also be interesting but I I always
honestly don't know what the answer
should be
another thing that I don't know how to
do is proven a lower bounds so I know
that when we're in a group even in a
complete graph we learn at least as
quickly as one person on their own
but I don't know how to prove that we
learn any faster
I know that we learn as fast as we do on
our own because I have my information
I'm going to learn that quickly but do I
get asymptotic do you get any
information from the rest of people I
don't know how to do that so that's
that's a nice open problem
but I can always take the first action
of my all of my neighbors and then all
my signals right because the very first
signal they're gonna act on
and then I ignore everyone else and just
continue using my own signals
but then your rate is going to be the
same thing again yeah
um
yes it's the same mechanism if the
social information is very strong it
swamps out the private signals but if
people stop looking at the private
signals then we're not learning anymore
and it can't be that the probability
that we're getting it right goes to goes
to one
um that's basically it so we have social
learning in a rational setting on any
network strategic agents they act
repeatedly and here okay I'm trying to
advertise a little bit because this in
general is hard to analyze but if we
look at the speed of learning we get
some tractability we're able to say
something
um and um and and and specifically we're
able to say that this rate of learning
is bounded from Above So no matter how
many people you have there there's some
limit to how quickly you can learn
that's it I have am I out of time or
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
um so you're looking at the model where
there is a large number of instructions
with the small number of people will try
but you take T2
yeah look at this like a large number of
people are interact with but maybe I
interact with them as much
is there anything you can
like one each person to interact with a
lot of people but a few numbers with
each person yeah so the total number of
interactions is still big
it's not like a fixed Network where
you'd have some other model you're
walking around the screen and just
talking to strangers yeah like open my
Facebook like I see a bunch of random
yeah but I opened my Twitter all I see
is better
foreign
matching model you just get paired with
somebody at random that sounds very
similar to what
um Gustavo Manzo here does with with
Daryl Duffy
um they have these models now you have
it they sort of take it to the limit of
Continuum and random matchings and they
see how beliefs evolve so people have
thought
so if students have the strongly
connected assumption would you get some
found on the so if you have sort of
different breaks for different engines
you still get something just sort of
analysis
all right so let me let me just give you
do we have a marketer here
so imagine that I have one person
who can observe many people
and the these people cannot observe
anybody
the person at the middle is going to get
a lot of information this person is is
gonna get these five independent signals
in each period so in fact if you have n
people like this n minus one people
around and one person in the middle the
rate of learning the person in the
middle
is going to grow linearly with him
um the thing is you're always going to
have at least one person in the network
in this case all of the leaves for which
this rate is going this bound is going
to talk
um yeah so your paper doesn't actually
need a strongly connected
graph
because what you're saying is that in
any graph it's not strongly connected
there's components so we have that
result in the paper it's sort of a
corollary of what happens in the
connected component there's an
interesting question which I think we
can answer
um you know here this person observes a
lot of people but what if you had a
one-directional chain like this
so this person observes nobody and each
person here just observes the person in
front of them they're it's not in the
paper but we're working there I think
again we're going to have a bound on the
rate of learning no matter how long this
thing is nobody's going to learn very
quickly
this could apply to more General
um networks so there's a lot of
questions here about what can be said in
particular
foreign
okay some Logistics about what's going
to happen next